una reunión de alto nivel pero con
expectativas bajas el jefe de la
diplomacia estadounidense estuvo en
sisjordania pidiendo calma tras un
aumento de la violencia Anthony blinken
comenzó su intervención oficial
expresando condolencias por las vidas
perdidas de palestinos inocentes
mientras pedía una desescalada y evocaba
la cuestión de la igualdad de derechos
También es importante garantizar que en
última instancia los israelíes y los
palestinos tengan los mismos derechos y
oportunidades lo que estamos viendo
ahora para los palestinos es un
horizonte de Esperanza que se encoge no
se expande
spanish el viaje del secretario de
estado de los Estados Unidos a la región
llega en un momento particularmente
volátil la semana pasada el ejército
israelí llevó a cabo la retirada de
cisjordania más mortífera en dos décadas
matando a diez palestinos en al día
siguiente un palestino mató a siete
personas afuera de una sinagoga en
Jerusalén este una escalada por la que
los funcionarios palestinos culpan a
Israel
afirmamos que el gobierno de Israel es
responsable de lo que está pasando en
estos días porque sus prácticas socavan
la solución de dos estados y violan los
acuerdos firmados y por la falta de
esfuerzos internacionales para
desmantelar la ocupación y los regímenes
de asentamiento y la falta de
reconocimiento del estado palestino y su
pertenencia plena a Naciones Unidas
Anthony blinquen aprovechó su
conferencia de prensa final para
reiterar el compromiso de Estados Unidos
con una solución de dos estados y su
oposición a la expansión de los
asentamientos pero es probable que
Washington enfrente desafíos que
influyan en el actual liderazgo israelí
con el Primer Ministro Benjamín
netanyahu aliándose con
ultranacionalistas y conservadores
religiosos que no tienen ningún deseo de
ver la creación de un estado palestino